la parole est à notre collègue rémy
pointereau pour le groupe l'est
républicain
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres chers collègues le 13
octobre dernier la cour des comptes a
publié un rapport sur les finances
publiques en forme de cri d'alarmé
concernant la baisse des investissements
des collectivités locales et cela pour
la première fois ce rapport reprend un
certain nombre d' alerte émise par la mf
depuis plusieurs années et je parle en
présence de son président françois
baroin cela concerne en premier lieu la
chute de l'investissement local entamées
en 2014 celle ci se poursuit en 2015
avec 15% de moins de dépenses
d'équipement des collectivités locales
cette baisse pourrait atteindre 25 à 30
% en 2017
sans compter les pertes d'emplois que
cela va entraîner dans les secteurs du
bâtiment et des travaux publics
aujourd'hui en grande difficulté cela
concerne également le coût des normes
dont l'impact budgétaire atteint des
montants significatifs ces 1,5 milliard
d'euros par an supplémentaires pour les
communes
sans compter le coût des politiques
nouvelles comme la réforme des rythmes
scolaires pour un milliard d'euros
supplémentaire ou encore des
augmentations de dépenses dans la
fonction publique imposée aux
collectivités locales avec la
revalorisation de 4% de la catégorie c
ce qui certes peut être contesté bien
sûr et tout cela bien évidemment sans
compensation et en voulant finalement
reporté la fiscalité nationale sur la
fiscalité locale et ainsi vous défausser
de vos responsabilités monsieur le
ministre face à ce rabotage financiers
nos élus sont désespérés nos
collectivités sont asphyxiés et nos
entreprises locales sont exemple alors
ma question est simple fit aux
conclusions de ce rapport alarmant
quelles mesures comptez vous prendre
pour répondre à la situation intenable
que subissent nos collectivités
pour vous répondre la parole et au
secrétaire d'état en charge des
relations avec le parlement
tu le gagnes tu nous avais et merci
monsieur vous avez la parole n'a pesé
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur rémy pointereau d'autres
questions abordées d'abord le rapport de
la cour des comptes que nous avons
étudié avec intérêt et pour lequel de
nombreuses dispositions déjà été prises
ou sont en train d'être prises notamment
en matière de normes sur lequel il y a
des effets très importants qui ont été
faits sur l'année 2015
on est passé d'un effet de 700 millions
d'euros par an les années précédentes à
13 millions cette année
en 2015 c'est un point sur lequel nous
avons déjà anticipé un certain nombre de
renards vous est ensuite intervenu sur
la question de la contribution de la
baisse des dotations qui représente je
vous le rappelle est vous l'avez
peut-être pas suffisamment souligné 1,5
pour cent des recettes des collectivités
territoriales c'est pour cette raison
que l'effort demandé par l'état aux
collectivités a été épargné les plus
fragiles d'entre elles les collectivités
les plus pauvres qui sont largement
préservé les dix mille communes
éligibles à la dotation de solidarité
rurale la dotation d'équipement des
territoires ruraux
vous le savez a été augmenté de près
d'un tiers pour se dire ces territoires
le gouvernement mène parallèlement des
actions significatives en compensant au
mieux les charges transférées aux
nouvelles et elle dans la loi de
finances de 2016 le gouvernement propose
la création d'un fonds de soutien à
l'investissement local d'un milliard
d'euros 500 millions pour financer les
grandes priorités locales 500 millions
d'euros pour les territoires ruraux
notamment sur les dotation d'équipement
des territoires et 300 millions pour
soutenir les bourrées centre-ville des
villes moyennes vous en discuterait
bientôt dans le cadre de la loi de
finances il est également proposé un
nouvel élargissement du fonds de
compensation pour la tva ces efforts de
justice de solidarité sont évidemment à
comparer avec les annonces qui sont
celles de la formation politique à
laquelle vous appartenez et la
péréquation que nous mettrons en oeuvre
entre les différentes collectivités
territoriales affirmera encore cette
solidarité
je bois trop pour 15 secondes vrai
monsieur le ministre le milliard d'euros
c'est un effet d'annoncé pour bien sûr
les élections régionales on le voit bien
et vous savez qu'il ya 160 millions
d'euros qui sont mobilisables pour les
communes
ce que nous demandons c'est un gel et un
moratoire sur les normes notamment
et puis un calendrier un peu plus
allongée pour la baisse des dotations
sur le long terme
merci tymoshchuk connaît